هذه خريطة لجنوب أوكرانيا ،
هذه في محطة توليد الكهرباء هذه أه ليست مهمة فقط
بسبب القوة التي
تضعها ولكنها في منطقة إستراتيجية أه
منطقة مهمة من الناحية الإستراتيجية وهذا
في الحقيقة أليكس صحيح هذا هو الخط الفاصل
هنا  بين القوات الأوكرانية
والقوات الروسية ،
الأوكرانيين في الشمال والروس
في الجنوب ، يوجد مصنع
زامباريسيا نفسه على الجانب الروسي ، وتقع
مدينة زابوس هنا على الجانب الآخر
على الجانب الأوكراني ولكن الشيء الرئيسي
هو هذا  تكمن خطة محطة الطاقة النووية
في مسار أي
تقدم أوكراني محتمل إذا
أراد الأوكرانيون قطع
القوات الروسية مثل هذه ، فإن
الزاباريا المزروعة موجودة هناك وهذا هو السبب في
أنه من المهم جدًا بالنسبة للأوكرانيين
الحفاظ على هذه المحطة آمنة مثل  ربما
يمكنهم ذلك إلى أي مدى تعتقد
أن النبات الموجود هناك
يبطئ أه التقدم الذي
يرغب الأوكرانيون في
تحقيقه ، إنه في الواقع متوقف تقريبًا  إن هذه
التطورات بسبب خطر الإشعاع
وما أعلنه الرئيس زيلينسكي للتو
أنه أصبح عنصرًا أساسيًا للغاية
لأن الأوكرانيين يريدون
أن يكونوا حذرين للغاية حتى لا
يتعرضوا لحادث على غرار فوكوشيما حيث من
المحتمل أن يتخلل الإشعاع
هذه المنطقة بأكملها  نتفق مع
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين على أن
الروس يحتجزون هذا النبات
كرهينة ، حيث أن الروس
يفعلون ذلك عن عمد ، ما
يرونه هو القدرة حقًا ليس فقط على
احتجاز أوكرانيا كرهينة ولكن الغرب نفسه
أه ليس فقط الناتو ولكن الأمم المتحدة
كل هؤلاء.  عناصر من
الحوكمة الدولية المنظمة
رهينة ما يفعله الروس هناك